good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday hope everyone's
having an amazing day thus far I know I
am because I get to spend the next 60
plus minutes with a girl I adore it's
Harry's Mom hey Harry's mom how you
doing darn good thank you for that
beautiful introduction Turtle luya oh I
didn't even notice you wearing my
sweater again yeah just missing you and
we have actually a really good plan in
place for your next visit we just
solidified plans so I'm just gearing up
with excitement going through your
things rifling through them no I never
put the sweater back in your closet it's
been residing in mine
um but yeah I'll just get a new one how
about that like it's yours okay
yeah
yeah it's so it's so clear when somebody
loves something you just have to let it
go you know no and you know I'm
literally the most generous if you kept
wearing my sweater that like you love
that I literally left at your house like
I wouldn't I'd be so happy that I found
a new life like I literally offered to
loan you my necklace yesterday because
you said that you liked it and that you
would buy it from me and I said instead
you could just loan it until I need it
back okay you don't like shove it in my
face I'm giving you the sweater like no
but just like you could just be a little
more generous when dealing with your
girl what did I do that was not general
just like calling me out
you know I don't really feel like that's
over like no offense like it's not even
that cute of a sweater don't even start
like you obviously love it just admit
you love a sweater
she said you want to marry the sweater
okay
I like your sweater I have that outfit
where is it is that mine no this is I
got an NPR from Spanx because I like I
kind of work with springs yeah I worked
with them and I got it too when she Lou
they're just giving them away
yeah no I got like I got two actually I
don't know how many you got but I got
two
where's the other one oh the plum one
no it's like a beige I wore it a few
weeks ago I was actually gonna wear it
this morning but I'm like all right I
should change it up I feel like if
anybody ever took a real look at the
clothes I wear on the toast there's
about 20 things that I rotate and it's
like actually embarrassing maybe not 20
like seven a few years ago we took a
look at like the Three core sweaters
that you were wearing like the period
sweater
um
I forgot there were two others
but you can make the case for both of us
now it's really just the bar sweatshirts
and any other sweatshirts that I happen
to acquire I'm just like constantly in a
state of confusion when I see people
online on social media like always
wearing different outfits where do they
store these outfits where do they buy
these outfits I I'm actually shocked at
how little I see outfit repeating online
well that's people's jobs to you know
give you fresh outfits every single day
and if I went into my closet and picked
something different every single day
like I could wear a different every
outfit you could too no I literally
couldn't like you have a huge closet
full of clothes that I can't wear I know
I I mean I actually can't wear mine
right now but like you could wear no I I
physically psychologically like I cannot
wear 75 of the items in my in my closet
I can't tell you why but like if you
know you know no I know
I know you know you should do a closet
clean out
like I do like biannually I do it all
the time
so what's the reason why you can't wear
them
I I can't really explain it it's more of
just a feeling I I mean I know the
feeling like they're they're irrelevant
to me either they're too big too small
too ugly too formal too informal like
there's a reason for for every single
one yeah no I totally understand
ah it's so glad to be back podcast with
somebody who understands me I'm an
understanding person turdy Lou you
actually are
thank you
um we've got a great show lots to
discuss lots of things continually
unfolding continually unfolding lots of
follow-ups obviously to the Scandal
which is the name that this is taking on
oh I love that yeah I don't know where I
saw it but then I saw Bravo Instagram
posted
um like an inter a picture of someone
being interviewed with that what's that
thing in Hollywood that's like
yeah the marker marker and on it it said
hashtag scandival
oh so that's the official name which
works for me because it also puts the
onus on sandable which really Bears more
of the responsibility here though Raquel
Is Not Innocent really do you think yeah
yeah I mean they're both they're both
extremely guilty the guilt is so extreme
everybody owes someone something but he
owed more
yeah because he was in a relationship
he's also much older yes so true and by
the way it's actually crazy how big this
story has become like Ariana and Tom and
Raquel are all being followed around by
Paparazzi there's Paparazzi outside
their homes and I saw pictures this
morning of Tom Sandoval smoking a
cigarette outside like seeing the
paparazzi and like smiling like he's
living for this like he's so
narcissistic I can't imagine living for
this
that's true delusion and true like
narcissism Machiavellian actually maybe
he is like he's the center of the whole
this is what he's always wanted it's
what he's always wanted you watch the
show like he has loved his modicum of
Fame and as it got it's gotten bigger
and bigger he's gotten more and more
unwell like he literally probably feels
like a rock star and by the way that's
all he's wanted to feel like to just see
his band but like do you not care that
everybody hates you no I think some
people like live for the the fame and
like the attention that's so crazy one
of them that never occurred to me like
when I think about them right now
I almost feel sorry for them like how
isolating and overwhelming and
overwhelmed and like where do they turn
to how they must feel I'm sure
I mean on the one I feel that way for
Raquel but on the other hand like I
don't know her I I anything I thought I
knew about her I don't know so I don't
know maybe her and Tom are like we're
the biggest stars in the world today
well Tom Sandoval was photographed
yesterday uh at walking into her
apartment building we have many an
update about the way she hasn't been
photographed I don't think she's living
for this like I I guess we don't really
know her but I think what we core know
about her especially like who she was a
few years ago like she's still very shy
um even though this is not something a
shy person does I I don't think she's
living for this for this negative
attention I think Sandoval is I don't
think she is I don't think she is either
I don't know how she'll navigate it
but like some of the things that now we
know about their Affair like they both
wore matching necklaces for months do
you see there's this lightning bolt like
that's [__] that's not shy that's
Brave that's diabolical yeah
so
I don't know I don't know her I can't
get into her head because I don't I
can't relate I know so we have a bunch
of updates we'll talk about that
um and I just wanted to like share a
little tidbit about how I got a manicure
pedicure yesterday last night for my
trip to Portugal which I leave tomorrow
for
um
and I was saying to you before I left
the studio to go that I would like was
kind of embarrassed my legs were so
hairy because it's like I'm getting on
my pers my things done and then I'm
gonna do my big shower before my spray
tan so I went to a pedicure with like
really kind of Beastly dead of winter
legs and I've thought this before but
like I don't know why and I feel like
nail salons are always evolving like
they're always trying to invade innovate
they're always looking for things they
can charge you for like things they can
add massage chairs heated chairs water
some of them serve booze now like I
don't know why nobody's innovated to
offer leg shaving well I would pay I
hate shaving my legs I hate shave my
legs or a wax while I'm sitting in the
pedicure chair like a leg wax I know you
don't like waxing because you don't like
pain but it's like
I would say a majority of women shave
their legs
yeah yeah no but like they they have the
waxing systems there it's kind of like
weird to have someone shave your legs
but honestly the way you sit in a
pedicure chair just bring me a razor
I'll shave them yeah no my legs are
already wet and they've been exfoliated
and there's a big puddle there I can
keep dipping the razor into and you know
some of us also need maybe like a little
little shave and wax on our toes like a
toe Box offer that I I'm giving this
free idea to nail salons all across
America I don't know why it hasn't been
done yet I think that this shaving is a
little complicated just like it's a
little not hygienic especially if you
really are going to keep like dipping
your razor into the water
but there's no reason why they why a
pedicure shouldn't come with an add-on
toe wax you have the waxing systems your
your you're buffing my foot it's still
on my foot yeah I I just think
I think they need to innovate and I'm
giving them this idea
yeah it's a really it's a really strong
idea
and then while I was getting my pedicure
thinking about how embarrassed I also
gave you another good idea you know how
they make you take your rings off when
you get a manicure and they put them in
a little bowl they should put them in a
bowl with add-on cleaning solution do
you want to have your rings cleaned like
they'll sit in a bowl there and by the
time you put them back on like they'll
be sparkling also a good idea charge me
so I went and throw my earrings into
yeah of course my toe ring my neck like
the bracelet I was uh I was there at
about five o'clock and it was really
empty which was nice we were playing
music and I was just like we had the
longest day yesterday we were
pre-recording a lot of stuff for when
I'm gone on Thursday and Friday so I was
really looking forward to just relaxing
and I find pedicures really relaxing I
don't find manicures relaxing and this
big guy comes in for a pedicure and he
sits across from me we're the only two
people in the in actually in the salon
um
and he's rolling calls while on his
pedicure I think he was getting like a
cleanup and like a foot rubber it's
rolling calls like one after the other
after the other and French in English
and I'm not sure what the third language
was because I had my airpods in and I
still heard it but it sounded like a mix
of maybe like Hebrew or Arabic and I
just kept looking at him but sitting
between us there was the biggest sign
that said you know if you have to make a
call please speak quietly and make it
quick for the you know
for the consideration of other all our
other customers I keep staring at the
sign and staring at him and like I was
really teetering on between wanting to
be a Karen but then also not wanting to
be a Karen I'm like my God have some
like an ounce an ounce of self-awareness
like it's dead silent in here there's
spa music playing I'm sitting right
across from you
oh my god get a grip I didn't say
anything and like I had my Beats airpods
in like those are noise canceling so if
I can [__] hear you you're being loud
you had the noise canceling on yeah I
had the noise canceling on and like I
was really
I feel like this is like as you get
older like you get to a place between
like wanting to like mind your own
business but also like wanting to say
what's right yeah
I didn't say anything and like I was mad
at myself for it
yeah I feel like I don't know you could
like say something to
um
the people in charge of the business
because it's kind of like then I have to
it's their job to enforce the rules but
then I have to give these like really
sweet ladies who are just minding their
own business the task of talking to like
this big man yeah you should have just
been like a big man and been like hey
can it honestly though it was so it
lacked such self-awareness it took such
[__] balls I'm telling you only like
a big man would do that and then also it
just begs the question like should men
be getting pedicures she's a big man go
in there with his big feet it's a place
for the girlies the the gays and the
girlies like honestly him walking in
there was a violation of my safe space
yeah even though it's worth mentioning
also that my husband gets pedicures I
was just gonna say it's worth mentioning
Ben loves a nail salon he'll always go
and get a back rub he'll get a leg rub
he loves he thinks like nail salon
massages are better than like a
five-star hotel like yeah when he'll
come home from work I'm like why are you
home so late like your meeting ended 30
minutes ago oh I just stopped by the
nail salon to get my back Ben will spend
20 for a 15 minute back rub any time of
day yeah so I'm I and it's like I want
my husband to have like nice looking
feet every once in a while but not if
you can't handle the responsibility but
they should have it at the barber shop
they shouldn't come into our space with
those big feet no and I always feel bad
for whatever technician is assigned to
the man's feed of course all feet are
gross but like they have to get out the
chainsaw yeah like it's next level yeah
and he was just sitting there with like
his legs spread like he was like so
honestly the gall
it the whole experience like was ruined
like my my 30 minutes to myself and it
really just made me made me think
about what
about what we're talking about how like
this is a protected space yeah
like and and stand up for your rights
turdy I didn't I didn't but I do feel
good about the fact that when Ben goes
into a nail salon without me he knows
how to behave because his intro to nail
salons were with me I mean women do it
too women do it too yappity yap yap I
don't know this was the next level
like it was a Next Level gall only a man
would have
in a woman's space in a woman's space
well next time you'll say something yeah
no I regretted not but I thought I was
being really obvious I literally kept
staring at him looking at the side and
looking back like really not looking at
your eyes
no he was he was every time I looked at
him he looked at me like he knew I was
coming for him he was just waiting for
me to say something and I should have
you back down yeah I backed down
I regret it I do next time you'll get
them next time how your nails and toes
looking probably better than most oh
gorgeous I might feel so good to go from
being an ogre I can't even tell you the
last time I got a pedicure because it's
like winter and I think for my trip to
Belize in December I honestly was like
[__] it so I do I truly I think it was
summer when I got up we got pedicures
together when you were here in December
um yeah we both had gel pedicures
remember we sat next to each other we
had a good time yeah no I remember that
must be my last pedicure it's not that
long ago December that's my last two but
I'm getting a pedicure on Thursday but
they didn't have time for man Care Plus
I sliced my fingers so I'm not really in
the position to get a manicure without
burning my fingers off what do finger
Band-Aids remind you of now these days
they remind me of Michaela but I feel
like for you they're my new Spy Kids
Junie Cortez who's married to Meghan
Trainor and they're also pregnant she's
part of your pregnancy crew yes yes
number two have you heard her new song
she's kind of getting dragged for it
what is it it's not the one I could have
my Gucci no that's like old now and she
wrote this is a song called mother
oh
but okay so like people I mean hold on
people are saying she's like really
writing music for tick tock now and it's
like so obvious but then there's also an
argument to be made like Meghan markle's
me I'm not Meghan Markle Meghan
Trainor's music has always been that way
and Tick Tock is just the perfect place
for her to promote her music and it's
why she's so popular on tickets no it's
like when you're an artist you have to
be writing for Tick Tock but then if you
write for tick tock like you're slammed
for writing for tick tock like and that
really is her genre has not changed like
since all about that bass like she
really does that like bubble gum pop but
some of the lyrics in this of course are
like a little cringe so if she's getting
some for the lyrics or the beat both but
it the chorus goes like this I am your
mother
you listen to me
stop all that man's playing in yeah the
man's planning wasn't great
wait tell me who told you
permission to speak I am your mother you
listen to me you're just a bum bum bum
bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum I
actually like that she sampled that bum
it didn't honestly people are
overreacting to it and it's so Meghan
Trainor like leave her alone okay but
I'm searching and she has a song called
Mom but it doesn't have the lyrics that
you're talking about oh sorry the song's
not out yet she just teased the chorus
on Tick Tock oh oh okay I am your mother
you listen to me so you can see people
yeah putting mansplaining in the course
of your song is never going to be a way
to win my heart over but there's an
audience for everything
I don't know she may have gone too far
right she may have girl boss a little
too close to the side she might have
talked too close to the sun do you see
that Tic Tac might be getting banned
yeah I know
I mean we've been saying that for like
years but there's a bill that's like
going yeah a few years ago like there
was actually a chance but then somebody
bought it a deal was made like an
American company Oracle did they were
the ones and they said like we'll take
over U.S Tick Tock yeah and then all was
quiet but now it's apparently like a big
enough security threat again that a bill
is Going the Distance I've seen the
argument for why it should be banned and
like I do agree but like I'm not gonna
be okay if it is I think you'll be
amazing
no you guys like I'm torn between you
know what the heart wants and what the
heart needs and you're saying from like
a Content consumption perspective
because don't you feel like a part of
you would be relieved that you don't
have to run in this Rat Race anymore
that's been like have this Chokehold
over you for years like kind of but like
I'm starting to have success like now
they're gonna ban it
um no I watched I'm going to your Tick
Tock how many followers do you have like
240k
and like I'm making money on it like a
[__] Like Girls Gotta Eat it oh you're
making money I mean compared to like
other creators and the fact that like
Tick Tock is their number one money it
wouldn't affect me no no it's it's like
it's at this point it's like
supplemental disposable income it's not
like the core of my business I think it
would if it did go away like a lot of
influencers would be screwed but I did
watch this 60 Minute segment all about
you know China and Tick Tock and the
youth and you know a good case was made
so I think it's a good case I think it's
it should go and I think it would be
best for everyone on so many levels and
yeah
and like the good news is we have reels
like it's so true it's so true like
someone was made a joke like where will
I get all my recipes from if tick tock
goes away and it's like I get my recipes
on reels come hang out like it's yeah no
and maybe now reels people will be
getting everything six months later
because everyone will be on Rails yeah
and like you could still create all the
stuff that you were doing like people
who were Tic Tac creators only have to
do it on reels now like
it wouldn't be it would be CR it would
actually be the most disruptive thing
that's ever happened to social media
um and it would honestly be very similar
to
Instagram video depleting Vine that was
like a cultural shift no but like Vine
natural organically became High relevant
nothing it really happened in like a
week no but like because the the people
spoke like Tick Tock is more pervasive
than Vine ever was it is literally
all-consuming for people not just even
kids kids teens adults everyone yeah and
for it to Just One Day at the peak of
its popularity be gone like we wouldn't
talk about anything else for literally
weeks no scannable would be over in a
second that's what scandaval needs he
should be on the house floor advocating
for this bill lobbying against Tick Tock
yeah yeah
um so I just feel like we've been
talking about like tick tock's going
away for so long
um I know there is like actual
legislation now it just doesn't feel
like it ever actually will be gone but
it might be
it might be so if you and you know what
we were literally talking last week
about like what we can do for mental
health and to be honest like I would
miss Tick Tock desperately and I feel
like I have a pretty good grasp on my
mental health when it comes to social
media but like like everyone else like
it gets to you
um I think it would be really good for
everyone honestly I think it would be
really good for everyone really good for
the country have really good Ripple
effects more people like might go
outside might talk to people in person
yeah I think it would be great so
we shall see we shall see shall we see
and it has bipartisan support so right
now I I don't know it could really
happen so if you're a Creator focused on
Tick Tock you might want to diversify
start a podcast get your reels like post
start posting reels before it times out
start a YouTube channel yeah have
something else for for the talkers to go
to because remember the last time it
almost went down
everyone started being like follow me on
Instagram like yeah there's not that
craze right now no because nobody wants
it was fool me once it's like nobody
feels like it's ever actually really
gonna stop yeah like the last time we
got really really close like the
president was talking about it like it
was literally 60 days yeah there was a
countdown it didn't even happen then so
I think people are like all right it's
the boy who cried Tick-Tock you know
yeah
we'll see we'll see okay well let's get
into the Mindless stories that you need
to know before you wake up
and have an amazing day
good one oh okay
you want to try it again no like even
though it was a little clunky it's a
good message
I stand by the message I completely
agree today's you know good message is
brought to you by bowling Branch stay
cozy all winter long with a set of
buttery soft sheets from bowl and Branch
they're made with 100 organic cotton
threads that get softer after every
watch so however you're spending this
winter season make sure you're getting
your best sleep with a set of buttery
soft sheets from Bowling Branch they're
made with the softest 100 organic cotton
you've ever felt it's the kind of
quality you'll feel immediately you guys
know we've been raving about bowling
Branch for years now and if you haven't
taken our advice like what are you doing
and if you have taken our advice you're
welcome you're probably sleeping amazing
with your buttery soft 100 organic
cotton sheets we are my house at home my
house at Jackie's house Jackie's house
oh we're a bowling Branch home through
and through they are temperature
regulated like I get really hot even in
Winter I get hot in my sleep and I find
that I stay really cool and while Ben is
more of like a cold sleeper his
temperature is regulated too they're the
highest quality threads on Earth their
sheets are made from slow grown organic
cotton for a superior softness and a
better night's sleep they're loved by by
millions of followers they've been loved
by three U.S presidents and they have
over 10 000 rave reviews they're
designed to feel incredible for all
sleepers they're made without toxins
without pesticides formaldehyde and
other harsh chemicals their sheets fit
the deepest of mattress and are labeled
with a top and bottom tag so making your
bed is easier than ever that's like a
nice little thing bowling Branch does in
their fitted sheet when you look at the
corner it's like [__] this goes on top
[__] just goes on bottom like thank you
how many times have you put your fitted
sheet on wrong and like literally
started getting under boob sweat just to
switch it get the most out of bedtime
with bowl and brand sheets get 15 off
your first order when you use promo code
toastbowlingbranch.com exclusions apply
Seaside for details that's bowling
Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Sundays Sundays is healthy and if
you love your dog as much as Jax and I
love Bryson Streisand then you know how
important it is to say yes to Healthy
dog food that's easy to store and easy
to serve Sundays is air dried dog food
made from a short list of human grade
ingredients Sundays was co-founded by Dr
Tory who's a practicing veterinarian it
contains 90 Meat 10 vegetables and zero
percent synthetic nutrients zero besides
USDA beef and all natural chicken you'll
find digestive AIDS like pumpkin and
ginger plus disease fighting
antioxidants dog parents report
noticeable Health improvements in their
pups including softer fur fresher breath
better poops and more energy the fresher
breath is a real problem Theo has what
me and Ben like to call duty breath and
it's because for so long we were feeding
him just like crap dry ass crap but
Sundays is a great great alternative
unlike other fresh dog food Sunday's a
zero prep zero mess and zero stress it's
shelf stable which makes it easy to feed
your pup top quality food and every
order ships right to your door so you'll
never worry about running out of dog
food again it also costs 40 less than
other Healthy dog food brands because
Sundays doesn't waste money shipping
Frozen packages instead they spend on
what matters which is sourcing the best
all natural ingredients for your pup we
worked out a special deal with for our
dog loving listeners get 35 off your
first order first of Sundays when you go
to Sundays for dogs.com toast or use
code toast at checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash toast upgrade your pup to Sundays
and feel good about the food you're
feeding your dog
thank you Claudia
your dogs are gay I've been stalking
your tick tock
why just to see what's going on oh what
do you find um right now I'm down from
like when you were in Florida and I'm in
the videos because I found that to be
quite titillating but I was gonna say
like I feel like um are you Shadow
banned like some of your videos are like
like there's one that has like
this one that has what 184 plays
which one oh because okay like tell me
you've never been on Tick Tock without
telling me it's friends only it's like
close friends among your close friends
well close friends is like who you
follow and follows you back so you can't
really control I actually don't like it
I never really post a closer because
just because I follow someone doesn't
mean I want them to see my innermost
thoughts yeah
yeah but it's a pretty decent formula
it's something it's something I love
close times even though I don't use it
that often I love the concept yeah okay
so what else Shadow band [__] oh sorry
um that our video our reels of like the
toes are not doing what they used to do
yeah no I definitely think when we first
started posting every once in a while
like one pops off but now they're
getting they get like 50 to 75k unless
there's like a major moment and then
like last week Tick Tock was like
weirdly down and like videos were
getting like five and ten views it was
actually kind of weird I don't know what
happened yeah suspicious did you post to
scandival tick tock yeah that's the one
my most wanted to talk I see I see
very fun stuff yeah I love tick tock
I can't wait to see all these videos on
reels
yeah you'll be waiting some time oh my
gosh what happened to all my tabs
turdy low I don't know how to use this
God forsaken iPad
oh my gosh
hold on for real
okay well here I found it okay thank God
first story all the updates in the scan
the ball one
Tom Sandoval makes a late night visit to
Raquel's apartment of 50 amid the affair
scandal Tom made sure to check in with
Raquel after Ariana dumped him after she
found out about their months-long Affair
the Vanderpump Rules start with spotted
making an after-hours visit to Raquel's
La apartment on Saturday night just one
day after their Affair made headlines
despite trying to stay under the radar
and an all black outfit and a baseball
hat he was photographed walking into the
building while looking down at his phone
Raquel has not been seen since all of
this started also
um TMZ claimed that this late night
rendezvous was not filmed though
everything that they're doing right now
is being filmed Sandoval's rep insisted
that he and Raquel shot a scene together
for the Bravo series before the reality
TV star left through a private exit
um
I think that they're filming everything
though but yeah no I mean I have to
imagine Tom Sandoval would only and like
Raquel to would only agree to let him
come over and like make this a whole
wave of news if they were filming a
scene together like that's a reason why
you would get together that's true but I
also felt like I was glad that he was
checking in on her you know because
they're like these two like obviously
what they did was so horrible but like
who can she turn to right now she has no
one and it's like I feel like if they
turn on each other which is why I said
yesterday I hope that they don't I hope
that they do stay together that would be
like one positive outcome out of this as
opposed to them blowing up their lives
for absolutely nothing yeah no they have
to get married at this point yeah so I
hope that he was checking on her because
even though he seems to be fine as you
say and like probably a part of him
loves the attention
those people would not for her okay
right now yeah no she's probably
struggling way more than he is because
he's like we said deeply unwell
um
Tom and Ariana I believe filmed a scene
together yesterday as well yes and so
what came out of that the rumors is that
like he pretty much like gasslet her
into explaining why while he was
explaining why he didn't tell her about
the Affairs saying that like he didn't
want to cause like mental health issues
for her and just like coming up with all
these excuses as to why he didn't tell
her about it
and apparently Kristen Dodie also filmed
a scene with Ariana
really and you know what I know she's
been fired but like this girl deserves
her
comeuppance like she deserves to be
Vindicated and after now it will have
been like eight years she is gonna get
her moment yeah and I'm happy for her
that's so she's also going on Sheena we
were talking about sheena's podcast
sheena's having Lala and Chris and Dodie
on her podcast this week
she couldn't get Ariana
no I'm sure she tried and Lala is having
someone
maybe Sheena I mean I'm sure they're all
just like on the one hand they're there
for Ariana's and apparently I read
Ariana hasn't been alone for one second
since all this happened her friends are
there for her but also like for the
whole ecosystem that comes from
Vanderpump Rules everyone's podcast
everyone's Instagram everyone's always
like everyone is doing the most here
yeah I I do feel also like obviously Tom
Sandoval a lot of the fans have turned
against him I feel like a lot of them
are turning against shorts too like just
because they're like this dynamic duo
and it like also it makes people
question like what was this whole
Schwartz and Raquel thing was Schwartz
involved in covering this up so one of
the other parts of the story is Andy
addressed like hit this I guess on his
show and talked about like some of the
red flags that at the time he didn't
think of it as anything but now he sees
it like in context so he says that he
noticed red flags before the affair
reveal
he said he was surprised on Wednesday
just hours before the news broke that
Raquel said on Watch What Happens Live
that she thought Sandoval was cuter than
Schwartz who with whom she'd previously
kissed she said he said I looked up and
said to Raquel oh you said Sandoval hmm
and then they moved on but then during
the commercial break Sheena asked Raquel
to explain her answer Sheena said to I
guess sheena's antenna was up and Sheena
said to Raquel you know I only picked
Sandoval because I knew you were going
to pick Schwartz and then Raquel said
well Sandoval has abs and kind of
shrugged so you know that was
interesting oh that's [__] weird I
feel like she actually like probably
slipped no I think
if this is the person that like she
loves like she's not gonna slight him on
air like it's an affair like they have
to be somewhat subtle
yeah but I think we would think and they
were so people think and people think
she's currently dating Schwartz that
whole thing happened two weeks ago where
she's a picture with Schwartz what the
[__] was that yeah yeah that's also
making me really suspicious of Tom
Schwartz
yeah well I think he was kind of a pawn
but wait he also Andy also emphasized
that at the time he didn't think twice
about it but after the news broke about
the affair he messaged Sheena imagine
like Sheena best day of her life any
message best day of her [__] life he
messaged Sheena to get more details on
the interaction but he didn't divulge
specifically what Sheena told him he
said I thought it was odd then he
discussed when Sandoval and Schwartz won
Watch What Happens live on February 8th
he said when Schwartz was on with
Sandoval on Premiere night there was
some odd energy between them Schwartz
was looking at Sandoval the entire time
almost for guidance on answers his
feelings on the odd episode led him to
wonder when did Schwartz find out about
this
I just want to say schwarzek looking to
Sandoval for answers is not like the
most new thing Schwartz is like
spineless he's kind of like a dope I I
think that was part of the reason his
marriage fell apart like I feel like
I feel like that's actually like who he
is he's always like what do I do yes but
in Tom's statement he said Schwartz only
found out about this very recently I
feel like he could have known about this
when they were filming Watch What
Happens Live and it's like if the
questions he I didn't watch our episode
of the questions that were being asked
were about Schwartz and Raquel and
Schwartz knows that Sandoval is actually
with Raquel how do I answer these
questions yeah I know it's it's a it's a
maze and then Andy also brought up
another tidbit of Raquel and Ariana all
watching Sandoval's band performed
during bravocon in October he said I was
at that show and I'm standing there and
Raquel's standing behind me and Ariana's
in front of me and you can see how
they're both looking at Sandoval it's
wild he revealed that he learned about
the affair on Thursday just one day
after Raquel and Sheena appeared on his
late night talk show he said that he
found the Revelation disturbing shocking
and upsetting and he also confirmed that
Bravo cameras have been filming the
whole ordeal and will play out before
the reunion Which films in two weeks
good airs good yes then also he
addressed uh
a lot of fans are calling for Andy to
fire Raquel over this oh no it's finally
good it's I know but he said that he has
no plans to do anything because he's no
longer involved in Vanderpump Rules
besides being a huge fan and hosting the
reunions he said that he has not worked
on pump rule since season six or seven
before reiterating I'm only the reunion
guy but some literal unhinged fans are
like Tom and Raquel this was a tweet Tom
Raquel should be fired for manipulating
and fabricating false storylines to keep
this dark secret they tried to outsmart
production and withhold their true
personal lives and still collect their
check this is aside from ruining
everyone they love for sport
these are the same people who are like
Jen Joshua to be fired even though she's
like an actual Criminal Who defrauded uh
the vulnerable members of our
communities
um and this is also like part of the
reason why I can't watch Bravo anymore
the fans are so toxic I actually think
they're on par with like salinators like
teeny bopper like those psychotic fans
grown up grown up I can't with Bravo
fans they're so not okay yeah no it's
moronic to think that these two people
who while committing doing something so
egregious actually just saved the show
that they should now be fired but what's
going to happen if we like go down this
road is that Raquel and Tom whether or
not they stay together or not will be
naturally alien needed for the group
nobody will want to hang out with them
nobody will want to film with them yeah
the ties That Bind will not be there and
so once the dust settles from all of
this yes I don't know what their place
will be but it reminded me of something
that you said yesterday
about this being the Vanderpump of your
because that's what would happen in the
early Seasons like remember Kristen
hooked up with Jax who's Sassy's best
friend and boyfriend and you would think
these people will never get over this
but like the Vanderpump crew like gets
over stuff so even though this is the
worst crime that's ever been committed
they get over the unthinkable over there
I know so I could see a world in which
like they all film together for years to
come or like really organically Raquel
and
Tom if they stay together like naturally
fizzle out of the group because that's
how normal human beings would handle it
but Vanderbilt rolls is on another level
no and they've always been like just so
forgiving of crimes that you like most
people could never forgive from a friend
yeah and a partner
yeah yeah no you're right I mean the
idea that these two should be fired for
this is probably one of the dumbest
things I've ever heard any human being
say uh Generations are being are getting
so invested starting the Enterprise in
the beginning this is the best thing
that ever could happen to the show and
while yes on a human level it's
deplorable what they did on an
entertainment level the the the idea
that they should be fired is [__]
moronic and people are so dumb people
are so dumb
dumb
dumb dumb dumb like that's what we watch
reality TV for like bad behavior duh we
didn't watch you know we're not going to
see like a bunch of saints doing charity
no and it's like back in the day before
Bravo had like a really toxic fan base
and Vanderpump Rules was just getting
started like nobody would have ever
called for Kristen to have been fired
when she slept with Jax that was like
the best thing ever no unless we never
forget about rules started with Sheena
Sheena having a conversation with her
ex-boyfriend's wife
from Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
honestly I feel like everyone remembers
where they were when the Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills episode ended and
Sheena was just a waitress and then she
walked into the restaurant in the first
episode of Vanderpump Rules began and
she was a reality star
yeah
that was a moment in time
it was and that's like where we started
so we're not so far off in terms of you
know you didn't come to the show looking
for Pious human beings we started right
with extramarital affair we did marital
a woman with kids like yeah that was
Next Level yeah this was the show about
the Mistress don't forget what you're
watching is there anyone on the show who
hasn't
cheated or been cheated on I don't think
Katie ever cheated on Schwartz
but she has been cheated on remember
your man made out with my friend yes yes
yes but like she is pious I'm saying
cheated or cheated on was there any
relationship that was a kosher the whole
way through you're asking yeah we just
found out James and Raquel wasn't right
obviously Lala and Randall wasn't Tom
and Ariana wasn't Tom and Katie wasn't
Jackson stossey wasn't Jackson Britney
Jackson Britney wasn't
what's wrong with these people
I don't know is there a singer uh so far
Brock and Sheena are good but we don't
know but yeah they're they're pretty
kosher yeah I think if something happens
someone would let us know
did Sheena and Shea break up for
infidelity or just because like he was
dead wait he was
deadly stealing her money I think like
yeah others that was crazy to hear
Sheena talk about her uh divorce yeah
it's been a wild ride and it's just
starting over again yes exactly so we'll
keep you posted I mean I think everybody
oh sorry there was one other big piece
of the story which was that
um Raquel's lawyers have sent out
statements to the cast because she her
intimate face time with session with Tom
says that she says it was recorded
without permission so the word on the
street is that the video that Ariana saw
on Tom's phone was a screen recorded sex
face time between Tom and Raquel and
then I guess that video like
disseminated through the friend group
but it was recorded without Raquel's
permission so Raquel says the intimate
base time session she had with Tom
Sandoval that ultimately led to led to
Tom split with Ariana was recorded
without her permission and she's gotten
her lawyers involved to warn everyone
about sharing it Raquel's lawyers fired
off a letter Monday to several cast
members and Friends warning that the
recording was done illegally without
Raquel's knowledge or consent her
attorney cited a revenge porn law in the
California Penal Code outlining
non-consensual photography making it a
crime to invade someone's privacy and
disseminate such material what's more
the letter warns any distribution of the
recording whether posted on social media
or forwarded to another person would be
a violation the letter doesn't
specifically accuse Tom of Legally
recording the conversation but sources
who have seen the video tell us it's
only the two of them on the call right
the lawyers order anyone in possession
of a recording to promptly delete it
from their phones the cloud or any other
manner or method in which the recording
may exist the letter ended with Stern
words of caution saying this matter
should be taken very seriously well I
agree with that like you know nobody
should be sharing that around even
though this is like a crazy situation
it's still
wrong
um but not her like not blaming Tom you
know yeah it's weird it's like half of
the illegal activity was it being
recorded without her consent and like it
wouldn't exist if it weren't for her
boyfriend I guess right you could call
him and so it's like how could you
really even continue to date someone
like that when they have done something
that's such a violation of your trust
yeah but they have to stay together
yeah
I just honestly I don't even know how to
Raquel could be attracted I don't know
how anyone can be attracted to Sam
Sandoval his personality even if you
think he's like good looking like in
terms of physical attributions one word
out of his mouth and he's the ugliest
[__] on the planet yeah I I
don't even know what he looks like
anymore because I know his insides
that's how I am about people though
that's so true I only see his inside I
don't know if he's objectively handsome
because I only like and that's how I
feel about like people on shows in
general but when it comes to Tom and Tom
though like I feel like Schwartz is more
handsome much more but it's actually
just because I'm only seeing his insides
which are more handsome insides aren't
even that great no not that great but
like they're nicer looking than Tom
Sandoval Tom is very conventionally
handsome like the classic standard abuse
Schwartz Schwartz okay
yeah I wouldn't know I can't see it no I
know what you mean I know what you mean
but he's definitely always been like one
of the more handsome people on the show
okay but they both said in the thing
that Tom Sandoval is better looking but
I guess Sheena only said it but but now
we know why
it wasn't because they thought it yeah
she Sheena was trying to be nice all
right I know Raquel's gonna say Schwartz
so let me say Sandoval so it's like a
tie that was actually a really
thoughtful thing yeah for Sheena to do
um she was always really thoughtful when
it comes to the guys in the group yeah
and that's what makes her so [__]
toxic
like a girl oh I couldn't care less Tom
Schwartz needs me let me run in my car
for two hours to get to his house three
times this week literally
um it's funny energy the Scandal is
splashing onto Tom shorts but for us
it's splashing onto Sheena well it's
showing a lot of people's True Colors
because like you can tell you really do
like you can and it sucks but like you
are who you associate with
yeah so like this whole time what we're
watching on TV sheena's up Raquel
Schwartz and Sandoval's ass
Red Alert red flag
yeah
alert alert
foreign
anyways I mean I really hope people
should not be sharing this video like
she obviously did something really bad
but like nobody deserves this that's
such a violation and this is a uh
a check in Dumas column because Dumas
had a blind item that like her crisis PR
team was fired they hired a new company
and like they were taking the angle of
like playing the victim in revenge porn
even though I don't know if it's not
necessarily playing the victim because
she is a victim of revenge porn here but
this is exactly what Dumas said her
first kind of statement was going to be
but then Dumont also said that they were
gonna
play the angle of like they are not
going to stay together Raquel is going
to act like she was like manipulated and
a victim of TOMS and like falling for
him maybe this is the first step in that
yeah yeah we're all just kind of waiting
to see like if Raquel says anything puts
out a statement I don't there's really
nothing she could say at this point I
don't know what I would advise honestly
I would have more respect if she stayed
with him yeah made this horrible
decision of course she should say
especially if she loves him don't break
up with him because we're all mad like
right no like you knew how horrible this
was when you were doing it so you
obviously have strong feelings and like
you you were okay with it so now that
it's blown up like
stand by your decision
yeah I was thinking about yesterday like
what's how
in what's a way that this could have
been made okay like say you fall in love
with your girlfriend's best friend
you guys will start having an affair
finding out like is the worst possible
scenario so I think anything would have
been better him coming clean yes yes
that would have been better I think
maybe him realizing he's in love with
her and not having an affair but
breaking breaking up with Ariana and
being truthful that he's having feelings
for someone else like there all would
have been bad but they all would have
been better yeah but you also know
there's like the rumors that they're
gonna play out this season on the show
that Tom and Ariana were in an open
relationship right so if you're having
feelings for someone else in an open
relationship is that kosher of course
when it's a friend it's a different sort
of thing I think the first rule of open
relationships is when you start to catch
feelings like it has to be addressed
either like you guys have to break up or
you can't see that person anymore like
that's the number one rule of open
relationships it's like no feelings yeah
and then if I think if you start to
catch feelings like they should have
went to Ariana
he should have ended things and then
they should have started a relationship
together if that's what they wanted like
it still would have been it still would
have been unbelievable and messy but it
wouldn't have been as twisted and dark
as this is there's no great way to
handle it but this was the worst by far
having Ariana find out by accident on
her own after seven months yeah seven
months that's a long time you know
you're in love with someone after three
months that's a long time to be a big
liar and it's Psychopathic it's
Psychopathic it's diabolical yeah
so that's the update of today
we'll keep you posted peeps peeps moving
on some more relationship news is it the
more relationship news that's brought to
you by stamps.com It could only be
2023 is already well underway so don't
wait any longer to level up your small
business and set up your year for
Success get ahead of the competition by
using stamps.com to mail and ship
stamps.com lets you print your own
Postage and shipping labels right from
your home or office it's ready to go in
minutes so you can get back to running
your business sooner Uso Jackie and I
are always going to be out here hyping
up brands that help you not leave your
house and stamps.com whatever your
business needs are for your small
business they're gonna make it so easy
because I feel like shipping and mailing
is probably one of the worst Parts about
running a business and being able to
print labels right from your computer at
home schedule everything from your home
laptop is a Next Level game changing
thing for 25 years stamps.com has been
an indispensable resource for over a
million businesses and the postage rates
just went up again but luckily
stamps.com has the best discounts in the
industry with rates that you can't find
anywhere else like up to 84 off USPS and
UPS rates plus stamps.com automatically
tells you the cheapest and fasting
shipping options so if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart so there's no lines no
traffic no waiting because you do it all
right from your computer set up your
business for Success when you get
started with stamps.com today sign up
with promo code toast for a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale there's no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code toast that's t-o-a-s-t at
stamps.com today's episode is also
brought to you by the perfect bar
looking for a protein bar that actually
tastes good we'll look no further than
perfect bar with their lineup of fresh
from the fridge protein bars perfect bar
is exactly what you've been looking for
no chalky artificial aftertaste here
made with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars little snack size bars
that are also good and good for you
you'll be sure to find something you
love hey Jax what's your favorite
perfect bar flavor oh I love the peanut
butter with the chocolate
and you keep it in the fridge so it's
nice and like cold and the chocolate's a
little hard it's really nice yeah it
really feels like a candy bar but it's
so much better for you they're so
filling I actually have to eat them so
slowly because they're just packed with
nutrition and that's even a snack size
bar so the bigger one is just like are
seriously meal replacements they're so
healthy and they're so tasty the snack
size are packed up to uh six grams of
proteins and 150 calories so a little
goes a long way they're made with whole
food ingredients they contain no
artificial preservatives and that's why
they're stored in the fridge which makes
you feel really good about everything
you're putting into your body you can
grab one after a workout for a quick
bite while you're out holiday shopping
or just you know to feel good about what
you're snacking on perfect bar knows
it'll be Love At First Bite so for a
limited time they're offering you a
chance to try their refrigerated protein
bars for free here's how it works sign
up for email or text and upload a
picture of your receipt from your local
grocery store and they'll reimburse you
for the cost of one bar it'll go
directly into your venmo or PayPal
account which is pretty cool all you
have to do is go to perfectstacks.com
toast to get a free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today happy snacking
like that's what we do here at toes want
a free snack here's how yeah we're gonna
find a way to get you a free snacks
so true
some relationship news Avril Lavigne and
Tyga confirmed their relationship with a
kiss haven't you heard how they rock
each other's words
[Music]
yeah that's a great opening for this
page six article Avril Lavigne and Tyga
confirmed their rumored romance with
lots of PDA on Monday during a Paris
fashion week event The Rocker and the
rapper were photographed kissing and
holding hands at The mugler X Hunter
Schaefer party at one point Taiga who
was notably wearing baggy clothes put
one arm around avril's neck and grab the
bottom of her face with his other hand
the musicians could not wipe the smiles
off their faces as they shared multiple
smooches in front of lots of people they
walked hand in hand through the crowd
with um him leading the way lots of PDA
lots of cameras so this is very much
their coming out moment since we
reported their thing at Nobu it was
unclear if they were you know collabing
dating she was if she was still engaged
to Mad son he didn't know they were no
longer engaged
um his rep at the time said they were
together and engaged Us of three days
ago when he left for tour so if anything
has changed that's news to him and then
he addressed the breakup on his
Instagram saying his entire life
completely changed over the course of
one week I just know there's a plan for
it all I'll keep my head up and always
listen to my heart even when it feels
broken oh that's sad I feel like there's
probably more than we don't know I don't
think Avril just like bounces from an
engagement like I feel like he's kind of
being manipulative that's also what I'm
getting so Tyga and Avril are like
loving lovey-dovey in Paris right now
and that is where mad son and her got
engaged
oh that's tough
um I feel like this is the weirdest
couple of all time like I can't get over
it and honestly
just seeing Avril Lavigne at Paris
fashion week is like also so Random yeah
she's like front row she's a fashion
girly what's so crazy is that if this
was a man doing this who left his
fiancee just one day who thought they
were together and then was spotted with
someone else like traipsing around Paris
they would be finished yeah but for me
it's just like another day of April
yeah but I also think it's like these
are three famous people who I feel like
nobody cares about like for real like
I'm not gonna get invested and be like
poor mod sun or go Avril like these are
three people you're not gonna say poor
mad son no I'm not like I quite
literally
could not care less and the only reason
I find this story even remotely
interesting because what an odd pairing
like this rocker I I just find them
really odd I actually found Avril and
mod sun to be like a a like a couple I
could digest because they literally look
alike like they're both rockers but like
Thai guys just so Random to me these
days like post Kardashian it's not
really a rapper anymore he's like an
only fans like I just find them so
bizarre no and what's so weird is I
wonder if they ever met as the plus ones
of Kylie and Brody
yeah at the same time they were both in
really long-term relationships with both
of them so I wonder if Kylie and Brody
are texting now like what the [__] you
know what I hope that they are because
that's actually really funny really
funny
and just like another you know
proof that everything revolves around
the Kardashians yeah this everything in
Hollywood this in particular
oh speaking of another thing from Chris
Rock special that we talked about
yesterday that I really liked was how
much respect he put on the Kardashians
yeah I feel like everyone goes it's like
such a like an obvious like cheap way to
get jokes like the Kardashians like they
love to [__] guys like but I feel like
he actually
um was really respectful of them yes and
no but it is overall thesis on them was
really funny yeah how like Kris Jenner
is the Statue of Liberty like anyone who
comes into her home she well comes with
open arms bipolar rapper Kanye sure
crackhead basketball player sure
um and then how open they were with
Caitlyn like I actually thought it was a
pretty complimentary yes and it's just
especially in comedy like everyone goes
like for the jugular they're like like
it's like so and everyone laughs it's
like so cheap and I was like ready for
him to do that and he did it and I
actually really respected that it was a
fresh Shake it's a fresh take and you
know what you have to be a lot funnier
and more creative to come up with
complimentary jokes because everyone's
always doing like ragging on the
Kardashians there's so much material out
there yeah
it was good
um and this is good I'm
I I mean I wonder what happened with mad
son but
um not really but obviously something
more happened than her her just like
deciding yeah they're not engaged and
running to Paris with Tyga because she's
like a long-term relationship girly
she's not like a Bop around the world
kind of girl like oh I'm sure she ended
it or they had like a big fight like I'm
sure something happened and he's like
what yeah
I don't care
I only know that mod sun is famous
because I've been told about him yes
exactly because everyone like he's in
headlines and it's mod Sun
right I have no idea who he is I know I
knew him my first intro to him was he
was like dating Bella Thorne my first
intro to him before he dated Bella
Thorne he dated Hannah Beth who won um
House of dvf you wouldn't know her
that's so [__] random yeah yeah
that's me a show I liked did you have
some dvf never came back
never to be seen again
ah good times good times are you ready
for our next story yeah some more
canceled television news but not sure
fourth story third turdy Lou oh wow okay
hold on tight the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show will return with a new
version after a four-year Hiatus the
lingerie retailer announced the return
of its iconic Victoria's Secret fashion
show during a 2022 earnings call on
Friday but fans should expect some
changes to the sexy Runway spectacle
which has been Hiatus on Hiatus for the
past four years as first for reported by
retail dive the company announced will
bring back its fashion show this year
after plummeting ratings and criticism
over its lack of racial and body
diversity caused the retailer to put the
event on pause in 2019. we're going to
continue to lean into the marketing
spend
to invest in the business both at the
top of the funnel and also to support
the new version of our fashion show
which is to come later this year the CFO
said I don't know what the [__] that
means Victoria's Secret has yet to share
with the new version of the fashion show
will entail but the brand tells us the
show will reflect who they are today
okay I have a call
okay I'm gonna make a good call I just
thought about it I feel like Remy Bader
is going to walk in the show she's like
has a big partnership with them oh
that's a good call I'm putting it out
there I said it first that is a good
call so I'm open to this they send Amira
and Amira The Tick Tock makeup Girling
okay well they said like that they
believe that they're two years into a
five-year journey in the turnaround of
their business and have a clear road map
to being the world's leading fashion
retailer of intimate apparel so one I
appreciate that they're not just like
we're making changes in our change like
20 years out of five years I'm like okay
we're making
um and I'm open to them bringing it back
and making it better
because you know ratings Plumbing it was
just completely like out of touch no it
wasn't for anyone anymore no I mean they
really lost me when Barbara Palvin was
there plus size like that was the
craziest if you are on your phone just
Google Barbara Palvin Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show and just know that she was
the plus-sizer but I also she's
literally a size six I don't need them
to completely copy and paste what other
brands are doing and I did better than
them they obviously need to make changes
but they also do have something like it
was at one point incredibly
prestigious to be a Victoria's Secret
Angel and so many I'm looking at all
these pictures and like these women are
icons so I know and so many of the
iconic supermodels of our time got
started and got their recognition from
Victoria's Secret yeah so
it was good
it was great for many years and I don't
even think people were so mad about the
lack of body diversity in the beginning
I think they were really justifiably
angry at the lack of racial diversity
it's like why literally why and I I got
the I got the body thing and why they
chose not to like they're selling a
fantasy a beauty standard like I got it
but like okay wearing the black models
like I understood that and then in the
culture there really started to shift
the to the body positivity movement and
they refused to get on board and I feel
like that's what really sunk them and
then all these other brands like Sports
Illustrated showed like you could still
be like a fantasy and you could still
give in to this like thing without
adhering to that you know anorexic body
standard yeah so it can be done and I
think Sports Illustrated is a great
example of how it can be done I agree so
I'm open I just
um
I don't know I hope it's still like what
was great about it you know is still
intact you know it's so fabulous it
looks really worse so awesome like the
musical performances and the star power
I don't need to see a bunch of randos
walking but whoa you know what it is hmm
why is it that like when a brand becomes
like diverse in body or race like then
everything becomes low budget it's like
oh we're doing stripped back no makeup
nude undies like why can't you have like
a chubby model with the glamor it's like
when they decide to become body positive
it's all stripped back it's all straight
back no makeup we're showing everyone's
pimples why why yeah yeah well
I would say I think uh Savage X Fenty
does a great job of if not like and so
you know they're gonna have to try and
find a way to differentiate and not just
act like they're copying them like a
knockoff but
um
yeah why does it get stripped back I
don't know because then it's like
we're being real it's not like a fantasy
anymore we're getting real give me a
plus size fantasy Give Me Wings give me
glamor give me big tits and ass yeah
like why it's like oh now that
everyone's included budget is cut like
what is that no it's not that a budget
is cut but like
if the aesthetic is stripped back yeah
the aesthetic you know it's like
trip back yeah yeah like what is that
and then it's like this sucks and that's
why we never included body diversity
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying so I
feel like they could be more inclusive
keep it at this level that they were
operating at yes but big glamor but I
also I don't know if they will do that I
feel like they might do a complete 180
and go for that like natural stripped
Vibe because they're they like because
they think that the whole thing was bad
and right right but it wasn't no and
it's like why why can't
inclusivity be glamorous and bold and
big and fabulous and expensive you know
we also have to feel like [__] after
watching the show like no again you want
to sell a fantasy you can include
diversity in that fantasy it doesn't
always be so Ron real and everyone's
pubes are hanging out of the undies yeah
yeah and like everyone is you know like
a model off the street like give us the
a-listers give us a list give us Ashley
grab give us give it to us yeah
but I don't know I think they're gonna
have another problem with who wants to
be Associated they have to just rip out
big bucks because of course A lot of
these models especially like Ashley
Graham are really really and yes
everyone has a price included from
Victoria's Secret for years like
everyone has I'm not gonna come and save
your brand you can go [__] yourself yes
everyone has a price but I do feel like
they're still there there might not like
I don't know that I don't know what her
experience is with Victoria's Secret but
I feel like there are some things that
some people can't be bought on like I'm
sure even for you like there are things
that you would never do yeah just
scrupled I get it but I can be bought I
do have a price I would rather see you
up there shaking that thing a hundred
percent even though I actually can't
think of anything on this planet I'd
rather do less than walk a walk down the
road in my und's on television yeah no
thanks especially if it's going to be a
strip back you know no armpit waxing
kind of thing it's gonna be hard to
Galvanize a lot of people to throw their
support behind this brand including
artists yeah who are probably gonna wait
to see like how people are feeling about
Victoria's Secret but you know
Victoria's Secret and I get now why
they're doing this Five-Year Plan and
why they didn't immediately bring back
the show because they've been creating
really long-term Partnerships with a lot
of people Haley Bieber is a face of
Victoria's Secret they did a lot of you
know Tick Tock or like I said Remy they
have these Partnerships and I'm sure
these people are in their contracts
gonna do the show
interesting so it might already be
stacked before they go out and try to
pitch Ashley Graham and it'll be stacked
with like their their Tick Tock uh
Partnerships are Remy who's obviously
like body diversity EXO Amira who's
trans and black so like they're doing
the work and that's why they didn't just
start with
it's better this way because they
skipped all those covidiers we didn't
have to see some like sexy lace masks
walking down the roadway so right you
know you're so right so like it kind of
worked out blessing in disguise let's
sing in Disguise yeah
we'll see that'll be interesting to
watch I'm open
are you open turd yeah I mean that used
to be the highlight of my year like
literally in high school oh my God we
were obsessed yeah like even looking at
these pictures like you forget how
sickening it was I know and like we
never even really got the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show with the you know
the new supermodel generation like
Kendall walked in at once no no she
walked in it more than once really we
did yeah Kendall and Gigi are here car
walk like with those supermodels like
they got it in
no Cara I don't consider cars a little
older than but she's in that crew yeah I
feel like Kendall only walked in it once
no she like walked in in a few years she
was like so little the first time and
then I'm looking at a picture of her
where she's like much more grown
let me look it was it was really say
what you want about it but it was a it
was a beautiful thing it was deeply
problematic but I remember loving it
even as like a chubby teenager like I
don't even think I really cared that
there wasn't
body diversity I just like like enjoyed
the show and the singers and the
beautiful women and like the celebrities
in the front row yeah she walked in it
three times okay thank you
so
so I'm wrong I wonder when it will be
yeah
we shall see we shall see are you ready
for our next story yeah it's a question
of a story can I ask you a question why
isn't Lady Gaga performing hold my hand
from Top Gun Maverick at the Oscars oh
damn yeah all of this year's nominees
for best original song at the Oscars
have been confirmed for performance at
the ceremony on March 12th this weekend
except for Lady Gaga's oh wait the
Oscars are this weekend yeah I'm gonna
be on the plane [__] that's a good place
to watch him if they have cable all
these planes they don't do cable anymore
except JetBlue DirecTV nobody else you
could just scroll through TV like it's
annoying that is annoying no if it's on
the TV that'll be great yeah
Gaga who was deemed a front runner early
in the race launch landed her fourth
career nomination for top gun Maverick
song Hold My Hand but is yet to be
confirmed for the show in the Oscars
condition tradition
um all nominated songs are sung during
the ceremony and everybody else who's
nominated this year will be singing
right now Gaga is in the midst of
filming Joker Foley Adu uh so perhaps
the filming Logistics are keeping her
from announcing anything but
right now she's not slated to perform
the Oscars are in six days doesn't mean
that she won't perform maybe she could
pull something together but to do
rehearsals and Musical and all that
stuff
it's unclear and that makes me sad
that's devastating because that is such
that was a big draw for me to be
watching me too 100 not only there's
like five drops probably
yeah Brendan Fraser
and Rihanna Lady Gaga
uh
the fact that I saw the menu triangle of
sadness like I've seen a few of them oh
yeah we tried but at my journey ended
with triangle of sadness who's hosting
Jimmy
for sure Jimmy
enough with the Germans
Oscars I need Lady Gaga I gotta like get
this together like this is important
it's a big night I know you already have
an Oscar so maybe you don't think it's
like that big of a deal but a girl like
get it together it's Jimmy Kim it's
Jimmy of the Kimmel Variety in my humble
opinion the worst of the jimmies
and there are so many
yeah he's the worst I think I would have
preferred James Corden I'm like I'm not
a James Corden hater no me neither did
you see Jamie Lee Curtis went on his
show just to say how wonderful he is
she's dull I feel like the more we learn
about her she's really like in season
right now would you say Jamie Lee Curtis
you are all of us
I I definitely would say Jamie Lee
Curtis you are all of us that's what I
would say except I don't know that all
of us feel that way about James Corden
but I like when someone gets so much
hate like I weirdly start to like I
always start to like them you know I
just start to want to
just not hate as much you want to know
why and we were saying this to each
other last week on FaceTime I feel like
every day we do the show and the moral
of the story is that people are so
unwell and then we come out here and
people are like that's such a bad take
Claudia and Jackie and it's like oh
coming from you I know I'm right if
everyone is disagreeing with us I feel
even more cemented in my my opinions
because people are so dumb and unwell
and I don't want to be the same opinion
as everyone no and it's honestly at this
point it's a pretty accurate Victor
scale it's like what do you all think
okay I think the opposite yeah so oh
everyone hit James Corden must be a
great guy yeah so I thought that was
really sweet of Jamie Lee Curtis because
she's so beloved and so she went on his
show and she said you know why I'm here
I'm just here to tell you that I think
you're so great you're such a wonderful
person and I just wanted to say that and
like I'm gonna miss you your show's
ending and so I'm like I moved on with
James Corden I'm ready too for whatever
like if he wanted was to host something
I'd be here for it if he wants to be in
another movie I wouldn't let it stop me
from seeing it yeah James 2.0 I'm here
for it yeah my phone is just like
migrating I'm just like so popular I'm
so sorry it's hard to be so popular I
put my phone on do not disturb me every
time we podcast I do and I do it all the
time but then once in a while I get a
call that I needed to answer during the
show or something you know what I mean
so yeah just you can't win you can't win
when you're like a world-renowned
podcaster yeah but our fifth and final
story are you ready for it is it brought
to you by Honey Love yes it is support
for today's episode comes from honey
love the reviews are in and honey love
came out on top for the best wedding day
shapewear with wedding season upon us
this is the ad you've been waiting for
whether you're the bride a guest or
looking for an everyday fit Honey Love
Is Your go-to for all things shapewear
honey love has revolutionized
compression technology so you no longer
have to feel like you're suffocating
while wearing effective shapewear you'll
immediately feel and see the difference
and we have an exclusive offer just for
our listeners get 20 off your entire
order with the code toast at
honeylove.com you could support our show
and check them out at honeylove.com use
the code toast I'm a shapewear expert
like you can trust me on something and
shapewear is one of them I'm constantly
investing in like good shapewear shorts
underwear literally everything and I
found honey love years ago through a
Facebook ad and I have been repurchasing
ever since so when you're talking about
shapewear
honey Love's best-selling superware
power short is the go-to it's targeted
compression technology distinguishes
between areas that you want more support
areas you need less compression and
their signature X targets and sculpts
the midsection without squeezing your
natural curves it's designated to work
with your body not against it the
superpower short is helping ladies
everywhere sculpt and smooth from
stomach to thigh by offering just the
perfect amount of compression and you
don't have to worry about it rolling
down because thanks to their flexible
boning it's hidden in the inseams and
that's pretty much unheard of in shape
where we all have been like you know
that role in our back muffin top hip
it's the most annoying thing honeyware
does not do honey love doesn't do that
treat yourself to the best shapewear on
the market and save 20 off at
honeylove.com with code toast that's
code toast t-o-a-s-t at honeylove.com
it's as easy to put on as it is to take
off
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
fifth and final story Jackson Mahomes
has been accused of assault by
restaurant owner and waiter Jackson
Mahomes the popular social media figure
and brother of Super Bowl winning
quarterback Patrick Mahomes no relation
to Austin Mahomes Jackie is being
investigated by police in Kansas after
alleged assault of a restaurant owner
and waiter last weekend according to a
report Saturday by the Kansas City Star
the Kansas City Star is making a lot of
news here at the toast yes you're right
Mahomes 22 allegedly forcibly kissed The
40-Year-Old owner and shoved a 19 year
old waiter more than once the owner and
waiter told the publication the
incidents occurred last Saturday at
Aspen's Restaurant and Lounge in
Overland Park just outside of Kansas
City Vaughn alleges Mahomes grabbed her
by the throat and kissed her at least
twice in her basement office at the
restaurant she said mahomes's advances
were unwelcome and shocking she believes
Mahomes was intoxicated she provided
video of the incident to the star and
local police the video is on Instagram
you can see it at the Kansas City star's
Instagram she also provided a photograph
showing a bruise on her neck after the
interaction quote he forcibly kissed me
out of nowhere she said and I'm telling
him pushing him off saying what are you
doing and then he proceeded to do it two
more times where the last time I was
pushing him off and I can see on the
cameras that somebody was outside the
office door and I was yelling for them
to come help because he's big and
massive the waiter told the star he was
pushed out of office out of the office
by Mahomes mahomes's lawyer provided the
statement to USA Today sports about the
allegations quote we have provided law
enforcement with the tools and evidence
they need to evaluate the claims against
Jackson Every interaction between people
needs to be placed in the proper context
releasing a short clip of the any video
does not provide proper context
agree it's literally the video you see
everything no yeah that's that's a true
statement releasing a short clip of it
of a video sometimes doesn't have like
the whole context but like what what
context is there for like
forcibly kissing someone who's in like
you don't know and having your hands on
their neck and she's reporting saying
like I don't [__] want this from you
right and taking pictures of her bruises
we have faith in the process and look
forward to a swift revolution of the
matter resolution of the matter this is
really disappointing because I feel like
during the Super Bowl I was like trying
to defend Jackson home so I'm like he
gets so much hate he doesn't do anything
and now he's here being a [__] animal
we were rooting for you we were all
rooting for you the video is really
upsetting like it's very vulgar it's
very like
aggressive and
what a [__] ass wipe like
this is just like you you know he thinks
like his [__] doesn't stink his brother
just won the Super Bowl he doesn't have
to work like I just
and what's so sad is I think his brother
Patrick is like a really great guy you
know like he married his high school
sweetheart and he is a kid now and he
works so hard and he's very humble
um
and just to like work so hard and like
really become so famous and so
successful to have your [__] brother
like be destroying your family name it
must be really upsetting yeah it is
really upsetting I don't know what tools
and evidence Jackson's team can provide
that would change any of this
um because it's seriously disturbing and
are Patrick and Jackson like close like
I think yeah he's always on the field
and like he goes to every game flies
with Pat like does everything yeah
no he needs to learn several lessons
because this is abhorrent Behavior you
can't go it's important Behavior I hope
there's like no I hope like the police
pursue these charges like to the fullest
extent not only so that he learns his
lesson but also so that he doesn't like
use his privilege to
you know get out of this and just get a
slap on the wrist it's like he is a
deeply troubled young boy yeah
this is a crazy [__] thing to do and
you do it when you think you run the
world and it's like you know by the way
you are in the place that you're in
because of your brother not you you
haven't accomplished [__] in your life
[__] like oh my God this video like
really made my blood boil like and you
know what I'm so glad she had the video
that's what I was gonna say released so
that you can't just it's not just like
he said she said and and we don't know
we weren't there like there is video it
looks extremely clear yeah what happened
yeah
well it's gross literally gross nobody
wants to kiss you stay the [__] away
oh my God this is really upsetting
I thought everyone was wrong about him I
was wrong I don't know I feel like
you've been anti I feel like you were
actually right about him like I feel
like you tried to combat your own
antiness because like he felt bad he was
getting so much hate he was getting so
much hating like at the end of the day
like he was just guilty at that point of
being cringe and like being a loser and
that's not a crime no but this is this
is a [__] crime and I was wrong and
you know what what everyone saw they
were right
hmm
I was wrong that's what I get for trying
to get people the benefit of the doubt
won't happen again
those are the best five I feel like you
definitely needed to know like all of
them definitely absolutely definitely
absolute mwah absolutely
absolutely positrutely
for sure
it's our second and
second to last episode of the week so
reminder that tomorrow is our last
episode of the week regular because I am
headed to Portugal tomorrow night
Thursday and Friday you will be graced
with episodes on patreon so if you're a
patreon member you won't really feel you
won't feel much
yeah we already have one in the can yeah
so it was a good one it was a good one
that'll be up Thursday and then today
turdy and I are getting together again
for Friday's episode so so don't miss
that patreon.com toast thank you so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
podcast anywhere podcasting events
that's about Spotify
stunning and wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have a great day we'll see
you tomorrow for hump day love ya bye